[Música]
segundo bloque económico aquí en directo
américa de france 24
nuevamente está en el estudio vamos a
hablar de alemania jorge donde el nuevo
gobierno quiera hacer frente a la
escasez de los trabajadores y le
pregunto cómo lo va a hacer bueno raúl y
es que la principal economía de europa
pretende traer
aproximadamente a 400.000 extranjeros
cada año los socialdemócratas del
canciller o las soes el partido
demócratas libres y los verdes
ecologistas acordaron medidas como un
sistema de puntos para los especialistas
de países no pertenecientes a la unión
europea el aumento del salario mínimo
nacional a 12 euros por hora todo esto
raúl para hacer más atractivo el trabajo
en alemania con una fuerza laboral
envejecida los expertos apuntan a que en
2030 la escasez de trabajadores
ascenderá a 5 millones de personas según
el líder parlamentario de los demócratas
cristián edwards el instituto económico
alemán prevé que la población activa se
de rus se reducirá de más de 300.000
personas este año el principal problema
raúl es que hay más trabajadores mayores
que se jubilan que los jóvenes que se
incorporan al mercado el laboral alemán
esta reducción de la población activa
también es un problema demográfico para
el sistema público de pensiones ya que
un menor número de empleados tiene que
financiar las pensiones de una masa
creciente de jubilados así es jorge en
otros temas la plataforma de comercio
electrónico mercadolibre muy popular en
américa latina compró participación en
una empresa de crédito moneda jorge así
es bueno se trata de una apuesta que
podría acercar a la región a la ola del
blog zinc y los cripto activos
mercadolibre comunicó de la compra de su
tía en group la empresa dueña de mercado
bitcoin una importante de cheng de
cripto monedas en américa latina así
como la compra de acciones de pactos
otro referente del blog si con estas
compras raúl la plataforma busca que
esos usuarios que venden y compran
productos en línea puedan realizar
intercambios en cripto activos al corto
plazo esta semana walmart presentó en la
oficina de patentes y marcas de estados
unidos una solicitud en la que
probablemente abre el camino para crear
su propia cripto divisa y una colección
de tokens no fungibles las acciones de
wal mart indican que no quiere dejar
atrás la interacción con sus clientes en
este famoso emergente metaverso así es
jorge y continuamos en cuba porque el
gobierno de la isla continúa aprobando
nuevas empresas privadas así que bueno
desde la histórica reforma que aprobaron
el año pasado y que abrió la posibilidad
de incluir a varios actores económicos
en autorizado en total más de mil 600
negocios ayer aprobaron 146 micro
pequeñas y medianas empresas privadas
así como una mipyme estatal y una
cooperativa no agropecuaria según el
ministerio de economía y planificación
cubana el 58 por ciento son re
conversiones de negocios que ya existían
y el 42 por ciento son nuevas empresas
en agosto del año pasado cuba aprobó
ocho decretos con los que reconoció la
gestión de las mipymes las cooperativas
agropecuarias y el trabajo por cuenta
propia como actores económicos aunque
estas empresas raúl son privadas tienen
varias limitaciones y un estricto
control estatal para muchos analistas la
precaria situación económica de la isla
y el descontento generalizado con la
política económica abrió paso a medidas
como estas 'jorge indicadores iniciamos
en asia
ahí el principal la bolsa de tokio el
nikkei cayó contagiado por las pérdidas
en wall street y las nuevas
restricciones en varias partes del país
para frenar una nueva ola de contagios
de kobe 19 en europa las acciones
cayeron por el nerviosismo en torno al
ritmo de endurecimiento de la política
monetaria por parte de los bancos
centrales y los débiles datos económicos
para finalizar que nos trae como cifra
el día juárez cifra del día por 2 el día
de hoy en la primera es 2.5 millones de
suscriptores agrego netflix en el actual
trimestre resultados por debajo la
expectativa de los inversores las calles
las acciones de netflix cayeron un
21% y la otra tiene que ver con el
bitcoin la mayor cripto divisa del mundo
cayó un 82 por ciento hasta los 37 mil
988 dólares este viernes es la caída más
grande de bitcoins desde agosto 2021 la
cripto moneda bajó más del 40 por ciento
desde su récord en noviembre de 2021
bueno las cripto monedas y su
volatilidad jorge muchísimas gracias por
toda la información nos vemos el lunes
con más economía quieren directo américa
nosotros vamos directo hasta parís
[Música]